talk so um the next talk is very much a
followup to Scott's talk this morning
about the question what do you do if you
have continuous variables logic and
Counting and so Jo will tell us about
way that model
integration yes
um thanks for the introduction um today
what I talk about is called waiting
model integration and um this are joint
work with my collaborators uh fi Paulo
Antonio
here today Andrea and
ke so in today's talk I first talked
about what is the definition of weting
model integration it sounds very CL
similar to waiting model counting um but
is in continuous
domain and second I'll talk about um
what are the wmi problems they are
tractable so in the continuous domain
things are very different
um from what we see in the concrete in
the discrete
case and lastly I will show how the DMI
algorithms can be useful in different
applications and specifically the one
I'm going to talk about today is on um
patient de learning um to see how things
are
connected um so
first um so we have been talking about
waiting model counting in this workshop
for several days and waiting model
counting is useful in database in
machine learning and here I want to um
write a simple example of weding model
couny before we see what this
integration so in Waiting model counting
we have this we are in this great domain
we have um our model in propositional
formula for example a implies B where
where both a are Boolean functions and
we can further Define ways over this
lros and then the task of weight in
model counting is basically to add up
what the ways for the satisfying wordss
and then we add up those
ways but now we wanted to move to mix
this great continuous domain to have
some continuous
variable in this case we are using the
smt
formulas um where we allows um like
linear arithmetic constraints combine in
a logical way so for example we can have
something like a continuous variable x
if x is greater than 0. five then it
implies that another continuous variable
Y is um less than
x and we can also similarly Define
weight fun functions over the lals um so
this is like the the case and value uh
this got show this morning basically is
saying if you satisfy uh this case X
less than 0.5 then you have a weight
function to be three if great than 05 um
then a weight one is
defined and then the task of W model
integration is again um to add up all
the ways of the satisfying assignments
so for example here in this formula only
this red triangle is not satisfied
because this is the case when X um is
greater than 0. five but Y is greater
than x so only this tiny triangle is not
satisfied but for the others they have
some weight function defined over them
and then what way model integration do
is to integrate over this green region B
basically the feasible regions to the
formula and then um to integrate the
weight functions over
them um so I like to motivate a bit more
of why we use the smt formula uh I guess
it makes sense to most of the audience
here so this is um an example of um
trying to model a skill matching system
where we want to model um the skill of
each player as a continuous f able and
also we want to model the team
performance using a continuous
variable um to start with we have this
each players um and they have certain
skill which is a continuous variable def
find between zero and 10 um and then the
players um further these players can
form some teams and here this is a
slightly more complex constraints
basically is saying um some pin
performance is bounded by the
performance of each player um by by some
number by
one and also we can introduce um Boolean
variables saying that um okay if a good
team can forms a squad and if these
people are score then the team
performance um will be
boosted so this is like one example of
how we use SM SMP formul as a model
language
and um um with all this we can combine
um this constraint to form a large CNF
formula and that will be our model and
if we want to further make it
probabilistic we can define weight
functions um over the lals as we have
seen in the previous case basically is
attached to each literal if some cases
are satisfied then we add we multiply
some waste so basically the smt formul
are or um gives definition of the
support of a distribution and this
weight function defines the density of
the distribution and together we get an
un normalized distribution in this
way and so this is a more formal
definition of what W model integration
do um basically integrates over um the
density
oh here it basically integrate the
density of all the visible regions and
then the task of wmi is to compute what
is the partition function of the
unnormalized distribution defined by
this formula and the the weight
function and now is the definition of
wmi um now we think can we use it as a
tool um to do probabilist probabilistic
inference as what we do to the uh
waiting model counting to use it as a
very useful
tool so here I would like to show you
one example of how we do inference with
wmi um so for example here if we want to
ask for for the model we have seen
previously what is the probability of
team one outperforming team two if team
one is a scored and team two is
not basically what we can do is with
take this query and we write write down
uh our condition that T1 is a scored
while team two is not and also we write
down our queries also in SMP formul
saying that the team performance of team
one is great than team
two and then we can
join the uh we can join the condition to
the previous model um together with some
waste and then we call an wmi solver
that can give us like a partition
function and then we do another call to
the D server on a problem that can join
with the
query and then with two calls to the wmi
solvers we are able to get some
probability we finally get the
probability of uh our query which is uh
like around 58%
here so even though um the pro uh in the
continuous case we need to do
integration um the problem we have seen
uh we we have just seen can actually be
tractably computed so it would be
polinomial in the number of players in a
in a team so even though in the
definition the dma involves integration
over High dimensional
space and next I will show you
how
so um next so now you already see what
is uh doui problem and in this
definition it seems very complex because
it involves summation and also
integration so now you might wonder okay
what kind of TMA problems are the easy
one because all the ones we have seen so
far seems complicated but somehow I also
tell you there's problem that we can
easily
solve
so I will first start with um the D
solver U that people have proposed so
far because um the the build of this to
server can actually help us understand
the hardness of the
problem so the sares we have so far
including um predicate abstraction based
um proposed by APO and also compilation
base um using Sid we have uh we have
seen this morning learning and also
there's um search based using the Anor
Anor graph by Rena and also lastly we
have some message passing base and we
are still actively working on um
building new doumi solvers and most this
effort converge to the uh PMI
library and first I would like to show
you um what are these suiz servers and
what ination they use um to efficiently
solve the
problem so given an onmi problem with
the formul we can um still introduce the
Primal graph um for formul by defining
the noes to be the variables and if two
variables shows up in the same Clause we
use an age to connect them very similar
to what we do in the discrete case and
then if you see such a primal graph then
you would think okay then we can use
context specific Independence because
here if we condition on variable X then
it seems all the other variables are
independent in this
case so that's how we do so instead of
doing um one integration problem Over N
Dimension so this is like um the the DMI
problem a simplified one that only
involves weight function over X and
weight function over X and also the Yi
variables that is connected
to
um so what we do is we de compose um the
problem like we switch the product and
also the
integration so basically what we do here
is saying okay given the variable X we
see it as a symbolic uh as a just a
symbol and then we do symbolic
integration conditioning on the X and
then um after a condition on X this
integration can actually be decomposed
as the product um of an tiny integration
problem and each this tiny integration
problem would be over just one dimension
uh Yi so basically a oneline summary of
what we are doing here is we turn a one
n plus one dimension integration problem
into n plus one number of one dimension
integration
problems and with this in uh with this
intuition we are able to build a search
based
servers um when it's appli to the the
star graph we have just seen this is the
run time so basically this is saying
previously um the problem with
exponential complexity Cann now be um
solved in almost constant time basically
this is linear time in the number of
variables and next I would like to show
you another the the M over um so it's
like now we see we can actually use um
the graph structure to derive some
efficient algorithms then can we do um
what what we do in the descrip case to
derive some message passing based
algorithms and here's um what we do is
again with the premar graph um we turned
it into a factor graph U by defining the
factors um to be like a subset of
Clauses that involves these two
variables only basically we break them
into subop
fers and we also have um a to run this
algorithm we have to run like some
upward paths from the left nose to the
root nose and the downward path um the
pass message from the the the the no to
the Li's
nose and then it involves um exchanging
message from um the the variable note to
the
factors which looks like the the product
here so this is basically product
gate and then we also involves it also
involves um Sending message from Factor
noes um to the variable noes and this is
like this is just like a add gate like
summation
gate and these are boring because so far
we don't see so what this message
exactly look like because because now in
our mind we know like in discreet case
they're easy like this message are
basically just um conditional
probability on true or false so they're
discret but what do they look like in
the continuous
case and this is this is what we get um
when we run the message passing for the
wmi problems so we also see this pwi
function this morning and it turns out
also this message are piecewise um polom
functions if if our ways are
polinomial so and this is strikly
different from a message message passing
algorithms um for the classical pgms
because we can see even in one dimension
it can be cut into like many pieces and
this is what creates um an extra
complexity to the inference
problem and
here we um here we also derive the
complexity of the
algorithm um the N is the number of
variables this C basically how how many
number of lros in a clause you can see
as a constant and is
exponential um in the graph
diameter so it is basically telling us
if we want to use these solvers to solve
or to trably solve a problem then thisr
problems has to have bounded
diameters um so this morning as scop is
saying One reviewer ask can we bound the
inference uh complexity using TR is so
um here is a similar conclusion where we
bound basically bound the complexity
using the graph
diameter so the
um a brief summarize of uh the the D
algorithm we have just seen is that it
is able to solve um DMI problems with
tree with one basically with is a tree
and also lock diameter basically bounded
some balance tree bounded diameter so
for this problem we can solve trably so
we're thinking then okay then what are
the other trackable DMI problem class
because this class seems very restricted
and only our so cannot solve it it
doesn't mean there's no other St that
can Sol solve uh the other problems um
so we want to look at what are the other
tractable TOA
problems and to do
so
um and to do so we first look at the
class that by increasing the treewidth
from one to two and still keep the graph
diameter to be in loog
scale and this is this class is very
close to the tractable class we have
now however uh we prove that inference
in such DOA problems um is sh be hard we
prove it by a reduction to um to to a
subset some problem and then we
construct something like a balance tree
but each each node has some tribis too
and okay so this this problem class
sadly is
intractable so we try another thing so
we keep the tri to be one so still a
tree and it's just like we increase the
diameter to be uh to be end basically we
look at a train and for train we know in
this great uh probabilistic graphical
models um the inference over such models
is trackable is um basically polinomial
in the number of
variables but surprisingly um for D
problems this this is also shopy
heart so together this is basically
saying what our solvers can solve are
the the only trackable class that that
we know so far um by increasing by SL
increasing um the hardness in the other
parameters would would um suddenly like
instantly give us some intractable
class um so here are the um and the
class I have just shown you is the
largest wmi largest trackable wmi
problem class we have fine so far um so
we are curious It's fa restricted so we
are curious is um can we have some
circuit representation for wmi uh when
we have some um some problem that are
worst case uh intractable because that's
what we have been doing these days and
also um in the example of the first T
server we can see that such problems um
they do have some uh some the
composability and so we wonder if we can
also derive a circuit representation um
with some certain structures like the
composable deterministic smoothness then
can we um have guarantee that aut
problem represented in this way can can
be trably solved so these are the open
uh open question and also um also
another open question is how can we
approximate the dma problems um so for
TMA problems they fine over uh dnf
they're FP but for Define over CNF
they're not um so it's still in uh
actively uh research topic on how can we
uh derive some efficient approximate
algorithms and now it goes to the what
are the applications of the wmi um so
because for WMC okay it's useful in so
many applications and now we have an
even expressive solvers um then what can
we do with
it so I would like to show you one our
recent work on using the servers to
build a collapse inference algorithm uh
for patient de
learning so uh first I would like to
give some motivation on what is um
patient dip
learning so for the networks are they're
notorious for giving bad uncertainty
estimation so for example this is this
SC this figure shows um the confidence
given by neuron Network um and this dos
basically shows the data and we can see
for um the uh for the points that are
far from the data they still predicted
with very high
confidence it me they are really bad at
uh estimating the
uncertainty and also this basically
shows a loss surveys when we train a
neuron Network and we can see this is
very complex and it can be risky to um
do your prediction using just one ways
one set of ways um from from the
training process and instead what you
might want to do is to base your
prediction on several different ways um
it's like you have have more models
together to make the decision for
you and that's why people uh propose the
patient learning for robust and reliable
predictions and one way to do Vision de
learning is the so-called uh bent model
average and so it's key idea is that
instead of making prediction using a
single model um so the basent model
average propose to average over
predictions um given by different
ways so it's like for each of the
prediction is weighted by um some weight
post theia and together they make the
they have they give the final uh
predictive
distribution and more formally um we
have the predictive posterior shown as
the integration here and then the final
prediction will be an expectation over
the predictive
posterior I were to compute the two
integration we seen here um it's very
hard it's very challenging uh one reason
is the main reason is because this deep
neur networks they are too big and
therefore it can be costly to maintain
too many samples uh um and also it can
be low sample efficiency given the
complex
integrant and I'm mainly talking about
sampling here is because as Robert
mentioned uh this morning so when it it
goes to inference over the neur network
people either do sampling or variational
inference where variation inference they
put some very strong like meanfield
assumptions over there and for doing
sampling uh is also not a good idea idea
uh because of the two reason we
mentioned
here and specifically here when I
mentioned it has very complex integrant
you might wonder how complex it
is and I like to show using the simplest
case possible like what is this
integration problem looks like when it
goes to um uh neur
networks so here we will uh our goal is
to compute the expected prediction
where the posterior is just a uniform
distribution and the nearer Network um
oh sorry the predictive distribution is
a gaan a convention used by uh the the
patient de learning
community and also the neuron network is
just a single
R and here is the integral survey of
this expected prediction so here we have
only two Dimensions so we only have one
weight in the neuron Network and one uh
the prediction is a one
dimension and to compute this expected
prediction it means we need to integrate
over this highly non-convex
multimodal um and there's no close form
this is this
surface so now going back to the basent
model
average um we might wonder
okay then sampling is not a good idea
for such a integral
service and is there a better way to
estimate the integral and
sampling the answer is yes and it's what
we use the W solers
for so next I would talk about first um
how can we reduce the spent model
average problem into exact integration
problems so we start with the BM problem
that we have seen we have just seen
where the Brun CH is uh very
complicated and now we know the sampling
is not a good idea because using just a
few to estimate such Service uh is not a
good
idea so instead we will like an
approximate representation that is very
close to the previous um patient model
average formulation but meanwhile it is
um applicable to exact
integration so here is what we get so
what we do is um from this approximate
formulation we result in another
integral service which is not a copy
paste from from this one so if you look
closely they're slightly different if
you look at this age but this is very
close um to to the ground choose one and
is amendable to exact integration by
using the waiting model integration so
basically what we do is we translate a
Rel near Network to an SM SMP formul
which is basically the support in the
doumi problem and we also translate
those posterior um distribution over the
weights over the prediction to be the
weight functions in the DMI formulation
and then we call thei overs um to do
integration over the the resulting
approximate
problem and this this will give us
really accurate
approximation um to the Bas mod average
predictions um but now you might ask
what about scalability it's the problems
that we always get um or generally
what's the price we pay for this
approximation
so previously we mentioned the for
sampling they're not accurate but
they're flexible in the sense that um
they can be applied to any new networks
and also they're scalable but for the uh
basent model average um reduction to the
D problems is limited to fully connected
layers and also integrate integrate um
over a poops in arbitr high dimension is
a shopy heart problems in general so we
only have high
accuracy and now we think um how can we
combine the good from both
words and the answer is um a scheme
called collapse inference
scheme um so next I'll show you how this
collapse inference scheme Works um so
given a neur network uh they might have
convolutional layers pulling layers um
some layers that we cannot do the the
MMA reduction like this um what we do is
we split the Ws in the neur networks
into two different
set so um we first um put some of the
waste into the sample set basically we
put the waste that we cannot reduce to
the dma problems and maybe some of the
way in the fully connected layers to be
the sample set such that the resulting
problems will be in lower
dimensions and then we put the remaining
Set uh the the remaining waste into the
collapse set and there we maintain a
close form representation over um over
its conditional Pro uh conditional
distribution where since we have put
most of the ways in the sample set we
have control over over like how large um
like how what is the dimension of my
condition of
distribution and then when I call a d
server uh on the integration problem
over such
distribution um I can know like what is
the estim estimated uh runtime or what
is the estimated
complexity and so finally um the way we
do our final prediction is to agregate
over um the samples we get from the
sample weight and then um for each of
the sub problems we call the D servers
and then we take the average as the
prediction and in this way we're able to
get accuracy because we do exact
integration over sub problem and also
this um this algorithm is flexible and
scalable because we have the sampling
part this is like some like rization
trick right um oh yeah exactly that's
exactly U like what we have in the
probabilistic graphical mode route yeah
um like to have sample some of them and
then for each sample we attach to them a
close form condition of distribution
exactly yeah the only I didn't get here
is what's WS versus WC like what I I I I
look at I'm trying to figure out
what's what partition in WF what partion
in the WC oh um so the way it's up to up
to your choice like to choose what ways
we put um so what we do is we put the
waste in those complex layers that
cannot be reduced to SMP formulars to to
the sample sample
set because for those um because for
fully connected layers with r activation
you can easily translate them Top by
saying okay if the input is greater than
something basically put the case as if
the input is greater than zero then we
have the output yes like that in that
case we are easily translated them to
it's brilliant because my question is
gonna be like RS I love because they
reduce PSE linear functions I love that
what what you do with the rest of deep
learning and that's the answer and I I
like it thanks thanks
um yeah and then we we try this
algorithm on the image classification
task where we have like really large
neur Network model there we're using the
rest net and then it shows we call our
approach to be Styer and so in this
experimental results uh what we can see
is we outperform other sampling based
problems in terms of negative log
likelihood accuracy and this e is
expected calibration error basically is
comparing um what the difference between
uh if you're near never predicts with
80% confidence are those if it predicted
really have 80% accuracy basically
comparing the difference so the for the
ECE basically the smaller the better and
we outperform almost outperform the
other baselines in all settings it is
basically telling uh we're applicable to
large n networks and it is able to give
accurate estimation of the uncertainty
and also it help boost uh predictive
performance um so this is just one
application and people also use servers
for um probalistic program verification
for fairness and also recently uh Thea
is Ser Ser as a back engine in under
symbolic framework so there can be so it
can be very useful um for many
applications um so now going back to the
open questions since this is a very
useful tool and can we build even better
uh wmi servers so it goes back to can we
build circuits for wmi and can we build
efficient approximate servers for
wmi and that's all thank you
[Applause]
you
question make me ask questions
I okay so I I really like the diameter
bound um and I'm just trying to figure
out are there any
assumptions so you handle AR arbitrary
linear you handle l l right for for the
the S&T part so AR arbitrary linear
inequalities right exactly and arbitrary
polinomial densities right pulling them
and and you're getting a diameter Bound
in that case I mean clearly worst case
is
like I I guess I guess you know my feel
with the XDS is I'm definitely solving
problems that you know were hard for me
to bound right and so so your your R
complexity must be much much less in
that worst case right um but the fact
that
okay so I'm just trying to see if you
have solved my tree width problem right
and you you you have you've given a a
diameter Bound for the the same case I I
was talking about this morning I see I
think this is like um like it can
improve it might be used as a solution
to improve the xad because xad provide a
compound representation of what are
those integration problems so we might
get um maybe go back to
the
slice so I I think you give me a bound
that I can actually provide for
graphical model which I wasn't able to
do which is brilliant um and then yeah
in practice I feel like you you can do
much better than the bound right um in
practice you can do much better than
than that bound uh in practice yes yeah
so when we try to run it even on the
train graph where we show it can have
like exponential run time and we're
still able to scale up to many variables
yeah it's a it's a loose bound but yeah
yeah yeah and what I'm trying to say is
for the xad is basically telling us okay
what are those M plus one dimension
integration problems it's like it gives
a
representation and I think with this
decompose um decomposability in this
integration problems we can further um
like solve the integration problem
problems like represented by the xad
like in similar way um basically to
further speed up the the integration in
the xadv so okay good
thanks um so uh so Minor Detail I think
I get hung up so like on on slide 36 I
think
so yes so overconfidence of basing your
networks with oh yeah here um back yeah
so like this
figure so so the left figure so you said
there something wrong with this left
figure oh yes what what's wrong with the
figure so like so like blue means
confident white means not confident
right yeah it's a two class problem and
essentially
like down there predict yellow up there
I predict red and I'm very confident
like what what's wrong here I see yeah I
can try to explain this in details is so
for every pixel in this image the neur
network predicts uh make a prediction
which we didn't show here but just show
its confidence yeah so it's very
confident here that it's a red
Point yeah like very confidence in so
for the it's only not that confidence
when is trying to make prediction near
the decision boundary like down there
it's yellow up there it's red with with
very high confidence yeah so for all
these parts why is this why is this
wrong um because like these are the data
if you try to make predition like far
from what you but it's closer to the
yellow so I would also say uh yellow so
why should I say ah if I go away from
the yellow maybe it's still a little bit
more red so it's still okay to say
yellow down there right it's okay to
definitely it's okay to predict yellow
so in terms of prediction it should
predict yellow for everything day on
this side should I down there become
more confident that maybe it's still red
so why um are you saying why it has high
confidence here why should it say oh now
I'm maybe more confident it maybe it's
still red so like it's still closer to
the yellow points right it should yeah
here it should say okay it might be
yellow but it might be something else
because this is like a I mean it's an
outlier down there right like it's far
from data if you're forced to predict
something what would you say yeah if
it's a perfect model it will tell you
okay these are might be lot outliers as
you say like that's a different
distribution that's the P of X we look
here at P of Y given X right right it's
like um so if I force you down there the
outlier which is still closer to the
yellow points I would say well if you
force me to decide I say yellow 100% And
that's that's fine I like I so I I I
don't see in principle why we should get
like more uncertain about the class when
we go away from the data but we're still
closer to the yellow point so now I ask
you to B right would you bet all of your
tickets that they are yellow or well the
point is now I give you a question so if
we have one model that tells you okay
here I'm 100% is yellow but now I have
another model that is able to tell you
this thing is far from what I learned
and exactly tell theage thing far from
what I learned and I'm not sure that's
in the P of X not in the P ofy given X
in my opinion P of X should uh dedicate
whether it's an outlayer so we should go
to a
whiteboard yeah we go to
whiteboard this is I don't know whether
this is directed to towards Robert or
towards
this maybe both so so maybe one thing to
to add because I I also Al created
pictures that look like this and I'm
partially with Robert that there's not
like it's not wrong and it's also in
part I think not wrong because this is
literally what you encode in your model
so like if you look at re networks you
literally encode you want interpolation
behavior and so in that case in in that
sense it's not wrong what what you get
there so you're saying the model is
performed this way by this L um
what I'm trying to say is that this
interpolation behavior that you are that
you don't want let's say like this this
is actually something that is like an
inductive bi of your model also ah I see
yeah I for for Val networks I see yeah
like given a NE Network performing this
way is not is not as bad like this is
what they can do at most I think this is
why we propose this patient learning
basically is trying to come up with
another model even though this is more
like Ensemble of near networks still
they want another model that is able to
perform differently so let me just add
so besides Rao and whatnot I think this
is a good uncertainty I like it and I
think it's correct and I invite
uh but you're one model and I disagree
with you I would want another model why
not just wait us all that's what she's
doing I mean I I disagree with you I
have a different model in my mind you
know and why not just wait you know give
each of us a wait which is what she's
doing num the benchmarks improve it
means the model wasn't calibrated if you
take Point Testament so there you Happ
yeah I my point is like if you do if you
do a really nice approximate in on this
it's still going to
extra it's not going to EXT like this
but still going to do that because
that's literally mod but should it be
99.99999% certain or should you have
some epistemic uncertainty there it
should yes
I so if if toy example here is a gaussin
bump of cats here's a gaussin bump of
dogs and now I take a sample over here
and I tell you this is the true
distribution where the data comes from
if I'm forcing you to make a prediction
here in the very rare event that I
actually observe a animal over here
which is to totally an outlier you
should be 99 to 99% ass that this a cat
yes yes
so you might be very close to you might
be closer to one ER than the other but
it doesn't mean have 100% certain that
he's a dog right I
mean but so here are the cats here are
the dogs and Anton is the outlier he is
a cat
99.999 mean something
different confidence Sor yeah I'm I'm
I'm talking about if this the true data
generating distribution it makes perfect
inference right the data actually comes
from sorry you're confusing your model
no no but I make a point about if this
was the true distribution
this
whiteboard then sure You' be 100%
confident everywhere that you're on the
side of the decision boundary so why do
you even have numbers besides
one right for so robertt volunteers to
lead a discussion after the break on
aloric uncertainty any questions for
just
[Laughter]
work um why why canot you translate also
convolution in ant formula convolution
with a relu afterwards because ideally
you can unroll the convolution duplicate
the parameters and still come up with a
fit forward neural net is it the problem
that the formula is too big the problem
is I never never
try so I just tried the last ler and
it's oh okay it's good enough that's
fair enough B people try with the last
layer all the times benar so that's
that's okay but that's a future work
like the question like what other layers
that can that can be encoded as as 7
formulars yeah and also what other
problems can be
encoded is kind of neat pecking
questions so in your slide about um
weighted model search um a few slides
L yeah it's one so I mean I don't know
if you oversimplify stuff but this is
like you're just doing variable
elimination right uh yes exactly uh
variable elimination in a continuous
word right but then why why are you
calling search and not just variable
elimination oh um because we are given
such graph the way we um compare this in
integration is we do some n or search um
so
um so where is the
search I didn't show it here um so
basically what anal search is saying
okay I condition on one variable and it
can have different uh instantiation and
then after we condition it to a certain
value then we ended up with a sub
problem they're easier to to integrate
but this is basically just enumeration
um okay I just create the computational
graph like a computational graph to
enumerate okay so another question was
when you show the